Mark, Scott, congratulations.
You guys have made it to
the third and final round
of this competition.
Now we're asking you to go
back to your home forges
and recreate this iconic
weapon from history.
[music playing]
The Dussage.
Ooh.
Yes.
Good luck, bladesmiths.
We'll see you in four days.
Good luck, buddy.
You're the man.
[music playing]
Here we are.
Ready to kill it.
I want to have this blade
shaped and ready for heat treat.
If I could heat treat
on the end of day one
I'll be really good in line.
Right now I am going
to start trying
to grind a little bit
of paper in this blade
and make sure that fuller sets
in as deep as I can get it.
Kind of thinned it
out a little bit.
I didn't want to grind too
much before heat treat.
That looks rad.
I like that a lot.
Once I got this
thing rubbed to shape
and got the bend in with
my little whacking method,
it was time to
just heat treat it.
All right, boys and girls.
[music playing]
Yeah, she's nice and straight.
Oh, yeah.
It's a hard blade, so I
can't stress how happy
I am actually inside right now.
[music playing]
It's day one.
I'm back in Emporia, Kansas,
and I'm making a Dussage.
The plan for day one
is to get the blade
forged out, thermal
cycled, and then hardened.
There's a lot put
into the handle work.
So I'm wanting to get my forging
done as quick as possible.
I always like to forge
thick, grind thin,
not have to worry about warps.
One of the hardest parts is
done, getting your tang done.
Now just put a point on
it, hammer the bevels in.
[music playing]
At this point I got
the blade forged out.
[music playing]
I get it down into the oil.
Oh yeah, baby, that's a
good sign right there.
No warp, it's nice and straight.
This is a huge relief.
It's like when you have to poop
and then you finally get to go,
it's just one of the
best feelings ever.
Beginning of day three.
I'm feeling spunky,
ready to get going.
Let's get to work.
Today is going to be making
that clamshell guard,
so I have chunks of lead
that I use for casting.
And so I'm going
to use that lead.
I think it'll absorb that
steel a little bit better.
The first thing to do is make
myself a die with rounded edges
and round nose.
I'm just going to smash into it.
That's going to turn
out pretty nice.
[music playing]
I was hitting it with
the ball-peen hammer
and realized that
I actually like
the hammer look into this
lead block a lot better,
so I just ran with it.
Dude, that thing's
fitting awesome.
End of day three, got a lot
more done than I anticipated.
So things are cruising
along pretty good.
Start out on day four and the
last part of the guard I have
to make's the clamshell guard.
So I just laid it out on
a piece of sheet metal,
cut it out, and started
working it from there.
Once I get the lines
put in the clamshell,
I stick it in the forge,
and I actually start curving
it to the shape of my fist.
Woo!
Damn, that's hot.
It's really important you get
it snug enough to actually work
properly and protect
your fist but also
it's not so tight that it's
just digging into your hand.
Guard done.
Final assembly, that's what
I'm going to be working on now.
[music playing]
It is the end of day four
and I'm feeling great
because I finished my
sword and it looks good.
Beginning of day four.
All I got to do is make
sure this thing's sharp.
Let's slice some fruit up and
let's see this thing work.
[music playing]
This thing is razor-sharp.
The sword feels
great for me, so I'm
hoping it's the
same for somebody
who knows how to use one.
It tastes good, too.
All right, bladesmiths.
Welcome to the kill test.
To find out what
kind of lethal damage
your weapon will do,
I'll take your weapon
and I'm going to put
some slashes and thrusts
on this pig carcass.
Scott, you're first.
You ready for this?
Oh, yeah.
Let's do this.
I am super excited to see Doug
chop up a pig with my blade.
I run my mouth all
the time like, I
can do that, I can do that.
So now's the time to see if
I can really walk the walk,
because I know I
can talk the talk.
[music playing]
Ooh.
All right, Scott.
First up, it is light.
The balance really allows
for velocity and recovery
with this blade.
And most importantly,
it will kill.
Yeah.
All right, Mark.
Your turn, sir.
Are you ready?
Heck yeah.
Let's do this.
I'm ready to see my
sword destroy, cut, slice.
But I want to see the
insides of that pig.
Oh.
[music playing]
It's just hanging
there like chewing gum.
All right, Mark.
Let's talk about
your blade here.
It's beautiful in its creation.
The edge is sharp.
I was quite amazed
with the cuts.
I was surprised that
it cut that deeply.
The one thing, though,
is that that guard right
there, that rubs on my knuckle.
Not bad, but it does
rub on the knuckle.
Despite that, it will kill.
Yes.
[music playing]
Hoo.
All right, gentlemen.
Welcome to the strength test.
The whiskey barrel chop.
Yeah.
Now, to test of the strength
and overall construction
of your swords, I
will be swinging
into these whiskey barrels.
So Scott, you're up first.
You're ready for this?
Oh yeah.
All right.
[music playing]
Oh.
First off, Scott,
this thing is
still a razor blade
on its entire length
except for right there.
You did take a bit of a roll
there and a very small chip.
But beautiful
craftsmanship, super light,
fast blade, very strong.
Nicely done.
Thank you.
Mark you're up next.
You're ready for this?
Smash them.
OK.
[music playing]
Here she goes.
All right, Mark.
Got an edge all the
way across this thing.
Yes.
You didn't lose a bit.
The only issue I have with this
weapon at all, as Doug said,
my knuckle rides right there
on the inside of the guard.
It's not chewing my
hand up, but there
is contact right there where
I don't necessarily want it.
It's a beautiful weapon.
It's strong.
Nicely done.
Thank you.
[music playing]
All right, bladesmiths.
This is the sharpness test.
The four pillar slice.
These pillars are wrapped in
different materials-- foam,
leather, canvas, and silk.
Scott, you're up first.
Ready for this?
Oh yeah.
[music playing]
All right.
Scott, let's talk
about your weapon here.
It is light.
Every cut it cuts nicely.
Overall, sir, it will cut.
Thank you.
All right, Mark,
onto your shiny sword.
You ready for this?
Slice and dice.
[music playing]
All right, Mark, let's
talk about your blade here.
That's a cutter right there.
You can feel the weight and
the power with your slashes
with this.
On the leather it did cut.
It's just because the
thicker kind of blade
that you have here it didn't
cut all the way through.
But overall sir, it will cut.
Nice.
Mark, Scott, both of you
guys turned in incredibly
competitive blades.
However, the judges have
completed their deliberation,
they've made their
final decision.
Our new "Forged in
Fire" champion is Scott.
Congratulations.
Mark, unfortunately the judges
have decided that your blade
doesn't make the cut.
Mark, when we have a
competition with two blades
that perform as amazingly
as your two blades do,
it comes down to judging the
craftsmanship of the blade.
Your blade rubbed our knuckles.
For that small reason,
we're letting you go.
Understand.
Mark, please
surrender your blade.
I'm bummed that I lost,
but I'm very proud of myself
and what I've accomplished.
That was a fine piece, man.
Going home because my
guard was rubbing the judge's
knuckles just a slight bit,
that little teeny tiny detail,
you live and you learn.
Mark is an amazing bladesmith.
If it wasn't for Mark telling
me I could do this, I got this.
Good job, buddy.
I'd be the one going home.
I really hope I make
my kids proud with this.
And the world gets to see what
Cool Beans Knives gets to do.
[music playing]
Well, Scott, in
one of our tightest
competitions to date you've
become the "Forged in Fire"
champion, and
that's a title that
comes with a check for $10,000.
Good job.
Thank you.
Ah!
I won, baby!
Yes!
This ranks up there with getting
married, having children.
Oh, yeah, I'm a Forged in Fire
champion, too, by the way.
What's next for me?
Get my 10 grand in ones so
I can roll around in it.
You know, normal stuff.
You know, what
normal champions do.
[music playing]